okay
um good afternoon everyone i would like
to call this special meeting of the
ottawa food services board to order for
february 5th 2022. i'd like to recognize
that ottawa is located on the unseated
territory of the algonquin and ashnave
host nation the peoples of the algonquin
and
nation have lived on this territory for
millennia their culture and presence
have nurtured and continued to nurture
this land the ottawa police services
board honors the peoples and the land of
the algonquin and ishnavik nation today
ottawa is home to approximately 40 000
first nations inuit and metis people
ottawa's indigenous community is diverse
representing many nations languages and
customs the ottawa police services board
honors all first nations inuit metis
people and their valuable past and
present contributions to this land
we are currently broadcasting on zoom
and live streaming on youtube given this
meeting is being held electronically i
want to caution that there is a
possibility of technical difficulties
should we receive any disruptions i
would ask that everyone remain patient
as we work to fix the issue and resume
the meeting as soon as possible i will
now proceed with the confirmation of the
agenda
that the ottawa police services board
confirmed the agenda of the 5th of
february 2022. is the meeting agenda
confirmed
confirmed confirmed
there are two items on the agenda today
the first one is the ongoing
demonstrations and the pres provision of
adequate and effective policing and
we're going to start there so good
afternoon everyone bonjour
thank you for joining us on short notice
i acknowledge that this is an active
situation and i do not want to take more
time than we need for this meeting today
we are on day eight of this occupation
our city is under siege this group is
emboldened by the lack of enforcement by
every level of government they are
terrorizing our residents
torturing them with incessant honking
threatening them and preventing them
from leading their lives people cannot
go to work or open their businesses they
cannot sleep walk shop go to medical
appointments or enjoy their neighborhood
this group
is a threat to our democracy what we're
seeing
is bigger than just a city of ottawa
problem this is a nationwide
insurrection this is madness we need a
concrete plan to put an end to this now
to date we have taken all of the actions
requested of us
chief i have called this meeting to ask
one specific question in accordance with
the police services board mandate which
is to provide adequate and effective
policing to the citizens of ottawa and a
reminder to all the definition of
adequate and effective policing means
all of the following functions provided
in accordance with the standards set out
in the regulations including the
standards with respect to the avoidance
of conflicts of interest and with the
requirement of the canadian charter of
rights and freedoms and the human rights
code one crime prevention
two law enforcement three maintaining
the public peace
four emergency response
five assistance to victims of crime and
six any other prescribed policing
functions
let me be clear i understand that the
board is not allowed under provincial
law to direct police operations nor do
we seek to do so
but we must ensure that you have the
resources you need to do your job
so chief in your opinion as the chief of
police in the city of ottawa do you
believe that you are still able to
provide given the fluid situation of
this occupation
adequate and effective policing to the
residents of our city and if not
what are the legal authorities you
require what resources do you require
from the board and what assistance can
we provide at this time
can go ahead chief
sure thank you i was just um thank you
you
sent your notes over to me and i was
listening to you speak and i was trying
to read through your notes and you said
a lot of very powerful things and
with a lot of passion as i would expect
from a leader of your quality and your
commitment to this city and um i reflect
on that and i share that
um but i am reflecting on what you said
and i'm looking at some of the words
here and you know what stands out to me
and i will provide my response but i'm
reflecting on
your impassioned statement the city is
under siege
this is a threat to our democracy
is a nationwide insurrection
this is madness
um
and then uh you've sought a concrete
plan and i will lay out what we
uh what the situation is of today and
what what our plan is and
um
and i will reflect on the definition of
adequate and effective policing
but before i do that let me just
in the briefest response extemporaneous
is again you've called this meeting
within the last hour and
we've come here as quickly as we can we
weren't prepared for what you were going
to ask or the nuances of it but so
please just take this as an
extemporaneous attempt to respond
to the genuine authentic efforts of the
board here
um
if i the comments that i've reflected on
as i look at the definition of adequate
and effective policing
there is literally nothing in that
definition of adequate and effective
policing that could
resolve a city under siege
that is in a democracy threatened
by a nationwide insurrection
driven by madness
i think you've just in your own
wonderful words described what my police
service and i have been trying to manage
on behalf of this city
for eight solid days
a police service under the police
service act was never created
the legislation supporting the police
service act was never contemplated the
oath of office that i and my officers
swore were never intended
to deal with a city under siege a threat
to our democracy a nationwide
insurrection
driven by madness
there is no concrete plan for such a
scenario as you described
i will though to honor the board's
responsibilities and duties
to provide governance and oversight to
the police service and to help us to
achieve a level of adequacy and
effectiveness
i will provide the best update i can on
the plan that we have
i have
i will ask just in advance i'd asked
acting deputy chief chris ferguson
um wg steve bell to consider
the request for a
a
resourcing
request um
this would be normally something we'd
want to take away as an inquiry and come
back at a future date with a fulsome
answer but i think that the board needs
the city deserves and we are inclined to
give our best answer in the moment but
please know we are working in the moment
based on what you just asked us so
without caveat let me let me begin
again i want to thank you chair for
calling the meeting thank the board
the full board is here
i have my full command staff here
actually yeah blair dunker is here as
well thank you thank you for having me
and the command team here to speak with
you i welcome the opportunity to speak
with you about the ongoing
demonstrations
described
in different ways chaired by you by
ongoing demonstrations
as i will always we will always remain
accountable to the ottawa police
services board our oversight body
as i'm sure you can imagine as as you've
just articulated on behalf of your board
colleagues this is a very difficult time
it's an unprecedented time
since this morning we've had a an influx
of of demonstrations as we reported uh
to the board earlier on this week into
the council
uh when when last uh we had updated our
numbers and i'll i'll see if trish
ferguson has more updated numbers but
around 1 30 this afternoon we had around
a thousand plus vehicles um a mixture of
trucks and other conveyances uh
demonstrators uh on parliament hill and
in the immediate downtown core
roughly five thousand
um probably more in numbers but that's
the rough estimate
as well as counter demonstrators
around 300 plus
somewhere between elgin street here
and city hall
every available audible police service
member is currently in active duty we
have no members on days off they're
either off on some sort of short medium
or long term accommodated leave
otherwise they are
all called back into duty and in
operational mode in one form or the
other the majority of which are in the
downtown demonstration area the surge in
contain area or they're doing police
services for the rest of the million
residents in the city
i laid out in my command team and i laid
out
the framework of of
the
latest acceleration of our efforts
to address the major risks associated to
the ongoing demonstrations
at a media conference yesterday and in
various discussions with officials over
the previous 24 hours in the subsequent
24 hours i'll remind the board i know
you're well briefed on it but i'll
remind the board
and the public watching of what those
three latest developments were
first of all deploying a surge of police
officers in the downtown neighborhoods
approximately 150 additional uniformed
officers dedicated only to patrolling
and addressing unlawful and threatening
conduct in the most impacted
neighborhoods specifically
center town lowertown and bywood market
i can tell you that that deployment
started immediately upon the
announcement the day shift had roughly
25
officers the evening and night shifts we
were able to get up to the range where
we thought we would be between 50 and 70
officers this morning
as of 10 o'clock we had deployed 70
officers and i believe the latest number
that i heard was we have an overlap
period right now and we're up around 150
officers over the course of a 24-hour
day in three neighborhoods that equates
to the 150 we announced equates to
roughly 20 to 25 officers per
neighborhood at any given time in the
day there are overlap periods where
those numbers will go higher and their
transition periods where those numbers
will go lower so it's not a static
number throughout the entire day but it
is a major commitment of dedicated
resources that were put in place
yesterday have been in place today and
will remain in place through to monday
when we reassess
what comes out after the weekend and
make adjustments accordingly
the second part of the freeze-prong
strategy that was announced yesterday as
an enhancement
was the expansion of the hardening of
the perimeter of the demonstration red
zone that was in anticipation of the
demonstrators that were coming in this
weekend
that was the audible police service in
the city of ottawa utilizing concrete
and heavy equipment barricades to create
no access roadways throughout the
downtown core
again extra efforts to direct protester
vehicles uh ingressing into park parking
zones outside of the downtown core
and parking of illegal parking by
demonstrators resulting in by-law
enforcement removal and impound this
included the closing
as necessary of inter-provincial bridges
highway off-ramps and roads
all of which was put in place
significantly more downtown roads were
blocked significantly more ramps were
blocked significantly earlier blocking
of
bridges still allowing emergency
services healthcare and other city
workers to access an egress across those
five bridges
all of which have been in place since
early this morning that has resulted in
a reduction of the number of vehicles
that we had last week which is up around
3 000 at the highest point and we've
hardened the areas where the footprints
exist the sir john a mcdonald wellington
rideau areas have not grown in size of
new vehicles being able to embed
themselves in there
the third area of it was uh
enhanced intelligence operations and
investigations national provincial and
local intelligence agencies increasing
efforts to identify and target
protesters who are funding supporting
enabling unlawful and harmful activity
by protesters
investigative gathering and laying of
charges the number of charges we've laid
has gone up increasing including
cross-border investigations involving
the fbi and national security
we have through the efforts of deputy
bell christian hino
the mayor and his staff we've been able
to shut down the go funding program
that's a temporary reprieve because the
funds are already moving in different
directions we are now going after supply
and fuel coming into the area through
investigations and intelligence
operations and interdictions all of
which were underway yesterday fully
underway today
let me return to completing my answer
and i apologize this is just trying to
me trying to give a fulsome answer to an
important question so i apologize again
um
so
we have seen the installation of
sorry
i will give the board an update on the
latest numbers around what we've done in
terms of enforcement investigations i'll
leave that to deputies ferguson and bell
after i wrap up assuming you want those
numbers but they're available to you as
updated as they can be
um ottawa residents are frustrated and
angry so are we quite frankly
um they have every right to be their
lives in our city are being severely
impacted by unlawful acts on our streets
the arbor police service our policing
partners are doing everything within our
power i think it's very germane to the
way you framed your statement early on
we're doing everything within the power
of the police services act as it's been
designed as legislation and as we have
been resourced onto that legislation
i am doing everything in my power to
keep the peace keep our residents and
our businesses safe
and allow a sense of normalcy to come
back in in the quickest and safest way
possible this is an unprecedented
situation but we have learned from our
experience and yes our mistakes and
we're committed to doing better and we
make adjustments literally day by day
and sometimes on days like this hour by
hour we are doing much much more
um we have deployed all available police
officers as i talked about you will be
in the process of swearing in 60
additional rcmp officers by the end of
this meeting 60 more police officers
fully sworn in full use of force
capabilities will be deployed into our
operational plan that will free up
additional resources to go into our
neighborhoods and better serve and
protect the immediate vicinity as well
as the rest of the city we continue to
erect barriers we continue to deny
access through bridges roadways and
highways again we cannot shut down the
entire city that would be as harmful or
more so than the demonstration but we're
trying to introduce vehicles before they
protest your vehicles and allow for the
normal commerce and travel of
city vehicles
as much as we possibly can
we are actively collecting evidence to
investigate all unlawful behavior we
have implemented through crown guidance
a significant enhancement of our
approach to criminal investigations in
this matter i can't provide much more
information on that at this time
otherwise it would frustrate the efforts
of our investigators to do very
important work to impact and interdict
the demons the unlawful elements of the
demonstration
we recognize there is unlawful activity
such as the building of structures that
is ongoing as we speak we are addressing
these issues as swiftly and as safely as
possible
earlier this week i stated that there
may not be a policing solution to this
issue i think you just reflected that in
your own words uh chair and i don't want
to put words in your mouth but your
expression is more impactful and
powerful than i was able to do so i
appreciate you and i have different
positions and we can speak differently
but i do echo and
validate your sentiments
from what i could glean from what your
statement said so thank you for that
um we have made efforts in conjunction
with the mayor and city city manager
steve kanilakis over the last 72 hours
to engage directly with the federal
government on a range of other options
including additional resourcing that is
what secured the 60 rcmp officers that
you're swearing in today
we are seeking we've been offered and we
are seeking additional offers including
analytical support investigative support
canada border services agency supports
legislative and regulation
interprovincial supports all of which we
have explored offered and our
commitments to move forward most
importantly
our
efforts around understanding what we are
going through here locally in the city
of ottawa and as you've articulated
recognizing that this is not a police
only city of ottawa only challenge
it is in fact a national challenge it
requires all three levels of government
all three levels of policing and justice
to be integrated around a sustainable
safe solution to this deplorable
situation here in the city of ottawa
however
the strains on our officers and the
strains on our organization are showing
i can tell you we have members of this
service that are on literally their
knees trying to continue on we've
canceled their days off
for some it didn't matter they haven't
had a day off in 12 13 14 days
they are working 12-hour shifts 14-hour
shifts and eight tomorrow shifts and
they have their families to look after
they're dealing with covid and they have
the range of human challenges that any
person has they come into work to
fulfill their sworn office and do the
best they can in these unprecedented
situations that we're facing while we've
had tremendous support and i cannot
stress an enough chair board i cannot
stress it enough tremendous support from
the ontario provincial police
commissioner tom creek a tremendous
leader there's nothing we have asked for
that he hasn't given and he's offered
even more today just before this phone
call the rcnp commissioner brenda lucky
it's always bad to name names and forget
names uh at least seven different
municipal police services from cornwall
kingston
london durham
toronto police york region peel region
waterloo region i'm probably forgetting
something and i shouldn't do that
because they've sent their officers away
from their families to come here for
days on end and to work side by side
12-hour shifts and longer with our
members to keep this city safe
the fact of the matter is we do need
more help and so you've asked a question
that needs an answer i'm going to give
you my best answer shortly i would
invite my colleagues trish and steve to
provide and blair to provide their own
insights as to what that might look like
i will frame it in the short medium and
long term
so
short term we need
an additional surge of resources
i will leave that to trish to articulate
what those numbers are in the short term
for us to manage the three-pronged
approach as well as the overall
framework of our plan containment of the
occupation and demonstration maintenance
of the surge beyond the ability of our
officers to not have days off uh crowd
management plans for the the the
flare-ups of demonstrations on the
weekends and the changes and nature of
the demonstrations during the day the
criminal enforcement and intelligence
operations being led by deputy fell our
ongoing efforts literally across the
entire range of negotiation liaison and
compromise to reduce the impacts on our
community as well as come to an end to
this demonstration
um the actions to remove the embedded
demonstration and encampments uh
communications broadly internally to the
board to the mayor and council to the
broader community and and the actual
interdiction of supports which includes
funding and fuel and supplies into the
demonstrators themselves
that is the overarching framework of
which all of our plans are aligned to
and where we need additional resources
in the short medium and long term
let me talk about the medium and long
term because i want to leave deputy bell
and trish ferguson to really nail down
the short term and again
and
and sorry ceo dunker
um
medium term this came to us in the
middle of the winter
with sub-zero freezing temperatures
minus 30 with a with a frostbite warning
from our own uh ottawa public health
it's going to come again in the spring
and it's going to come again in the
summer and it will likely continue on in
the medium term we need resources to
sustain us beyond this current iteration
in the longer term
there's something that's changed in our
democratic fabric and chair you
articulated that beautifully and
passionately early on there's something
that's changed in the democratic fabric
of the nation
we have to anticipate that there will be
similar type of
my words demonstrations your word
insurrection
that could afflict the nation's capital
year in and year out
we do not have the legislation under the
current police services act
we do not have the resources under what
is now currently described as adequate
effective policing resources
and we do not have the justice system
framework or the multilateral agreements
between three levels of government in
order for us to predictably and
effectively manage such situations going
forward coming out of this and there
will be a coming out of this but coming
out of this we're going to have to
revisit the fundamental principles
of the police services act
how we are
enabled through that act and how that
act is
integrated with
other provincial statutes federal
statutes and agencies and governments
that control them
again i appreciate it i've said a lot
there but it's a very important question
you've asked and it requires a
thoughtful answer and i've tried my best
to do that
again i just want to conclude with some
comments
we would like to be able to explain more
about our operational plans beyond the
public realm
please understand if we provide too many
details in this form it will frustrate
if not create a failing point for some
of the things we're trying to do
we want to keep you and the board as
up-to-date as possible as informed as
possible and give you the best chance to
ask questions
but some of the details and nuances we
may not be able to do in this form i
just caution that in case there are
questions that come later and i offer
what i can as a simple solution to go in
camera i will leave that to your good
judgment chair and do our best to comply
within the laws provide the full amount
of information
possible and with that i will ask deputy
chief ferguson first to give her
thoughts on what resources legislative
changes or other enablements that will
help with the core operation and then
turn things over to deputy chief bell
and finally i would ask uh ceo dunker
for her own thoughts again
we can be if given more time more
reflective and come back with a more
detailed set of requests but again this
is in the moment trish over to you
thank you chief and good afternoon
everybody
um
so obviously these are rough numbers
given that this was a last minute
request but what i can tell you is it
takes us about 495 officers for a
24-hour cycle to staff this right now
so
the amount of officers we have simply
dedicated to front line uh for the
ottawa police service is 478.
so that tells you that it is every
single platoon officer plus that we
require to do this this is now day eight
and so we have had as the chief alluded
to help from a number of our partners
and and it's the only way we've been
able to do this
um
for the city itself
um for a 24-hour period we have on
average 150 officers just to cover what
we need across from cumberland to
uh arn prior
uh so that's just basic staffing of our
cars to answer 911 calls for this demo
for the footprint that we need to hold
for all the traffic positions that we
need to have and shutting down the
streets and you see
there's calls for shutting down even
more but for us to do what we have done
with what we have right now it's 225
officers to address that
and finally
for the surge that we announced on uh
friday morning it was 120 officers and
that's over again over 24-hour period so
um 40 officers in those
in those neighborhoods rotating
right now i can tell you that we put out
164 officers um
at our one o'clock briefing so that
is on top of we had a number uh out
earlier on and i hesitate to give you
exactly how many
officers are on the street right now for
safety purposes
obviously that that puts their safety at
jeopardy and i really don't want to be
doing that but i want to be able to
explain to you and for everybody to have
a really a good sense as to what
what we we need to get things going in
terms of legislative obviously the
nation's capital we we're dealing with a
number of different um
locations confederation park is a very
good example and and the national
capital uh
ncc has um access or or rather has a
number of of
parks
and um streets in the city so there's
there's enforcement uh authorities that
we are limited in what we can do so i'll
give you the example of confederation
park uh everybody wondering why we
couldn't just go in there and and tear
everything down and kick everybody out
we are not the property owners of of
confederation park and so we have to go
through the ncc
um that takes some time that takes some
dialogue to make sure that we are
you know having the conversations with
the right people our officers on the
ground
you know while they're equipped with
phones they don't have the phone number
for for mr nussbaum to be able to make
that call directly so some of those
things take time when we were in there
last night there was um indication that
this was an indigenous um
an indigenous protest or an indigenous
demonstration and so
lessons learned um by not
uh creating any any further problems we
went straight to uh engaging our
indigenous elders which we had already
proactively included in
in the um
conversation and we were able to get
them down and they helped and negotiated
along with our provincial our police
liaison teams with the opp
provincial liaison team
and uh we got to a stalemate late into
the night but we had to let those things
happen um we needed to make sure that
when we did get to a place where we said
we can no longer negotiate they're over
it was it was done on our part in good
faith and we provided every opportunity
for those people to leave on their own
and not escalate the situation further
so i give you that example as a reason
that i know everybody's looking to
confederation park saying why don't you
just go in there with bulldozers and
take it down there were children there
were women there were a number of things
in there we assessed the safety we went
to make sure that we did not have any
any flammable
situation we brought in the fire
department all of these things take time
and and a lot of dialogue in order to be
able to manage it in a way that we are
not going to be putting anybody at undue
risk or harm and and it's it's difficult
when you've got uh you know
a number of counselors and everybody
saying get in there and do it and
obviously the
the public is is fed up with the
situation and we totally understand that
but we cannot
um
then throw all of the other things that
we have learned from past uh
demonstrations of the book out the
window
so i i share that with you just as a a
small story of
what i think is happening on on many
street corners in this city during the
last eight days because it's a very
complicated layered um
municipal provincial and federal
statutes that we need to keep in mind i
will turn it over to steve now
thank you very much and good afternoon
everyone um
so in terms of intelligence we continue
to gather and gain intelligence about
what the situation is um our
intelligence to date has been improving
and growing our partners have been
increasingly
uh helping us to bring a more clear
picture of what's occurring uh we were
fairly accurate in our estimates today
uh which is not a good thing because
it's not who we want in our city but
it's a good thing from a planning and
response perspective
um in terms of our investigations today
we've had over 400 calls for service
directly related to the protest and from
that we've initiated over 50 criminal
investigations including uh 11 hate hate
crime related investigations that to
date have resulted in the charges of
four people relaying of seven different
charges that contin that number
continues to grow on a daily basis we
have dedicated investigative teams who
are
aligned to the protest and responsive to
everything that is being brought in and
we're starting to see an increase with
the increased presence in in center town
of the market and lower town we're
beginning to see more an increase in
criminal interactions and an increase in
our arrests to come in
um so that's the where we are right now
in terms of intelligence and
investigations
sorry steve can you lay out any
additional resources legislative change
that we would need in short medium or
last week for sure chief thank you very
much so um i
i believe that we're going to need an
investment in all three areas that i'm
responsible for first one would be
investigative resources but she chief
spoke at a high level of
an approach that we would be starting to
entertain that will take investigative
resources to both support whatever sort
of investigation we launch into as well
as prepare what whatever sort of
and ultimate criminal prosecution that
we would enter into what i will say is
we've had amazing cooperation from the
crown attorney's office
who continue to work with us on a daily
basis in terms of how
we attack this from a criminal code
perspective so i would we would see need
to see an augmentation of
investigators probably in the 30 to 40
range to be able to help manage and take
on this type of investigation in the
very short term
we will need increased intelligence
resources particularly as it would
relate to cyber crime capacity and
social media scanning we know that the
groups that we have uh are
interfacing with have amazing social
media capacities and skills and have the
ability to widely spread a message
and a narrative
that needs to continually be followed up
and investigated so we would need to
seek out increased cyber probabilities
and increased intelligence resources
particularly around social media
from an information perspective we know
we are taxing our all of our frontline
members and our front line members i
include our police communicators they
are
they are the brunt of the beginning of
many many calls of dissatisfaction uh
understandably and they are extremely
taxed in trying to manage the operations
that we have established within the core
as well as maintain a presence and of
the ability for a service to respond to
the rest of the city we would need to
see an increase in augmentation of our
communications staff beyond that as we
get uh
as we start to progress through
the next steps of the dismantling the
demobilization of the protest we know
that we're going to have evidence
management evidence gathering and
evidence storage challenges so we would
need actual resources physical buildings
to be able to establish to maintain
catalog and store the vast amount of
evidence that we could be stealing this
could be
sourcing or taking in as well as
processing people who may
be criminally charged as a result of
this uh beyond that the only other area
i would actually highlight would be
around legal resources we are extremely
taxing our legal team to provide
up-to-date adequate
and forward-thinking and innovative
legal services and legal perspectives on
how to how we can look at taking old
legislation that doesn't fit the problem
we have in front of us and utilizing it
to be able to have allow us to have
success in in finalizing this so i do
believe that we would need increase in
our legal resources as well as the
ability
to have uh advocacy for
immediate possibly short-term but
immediate legislative changes that would
allow us increased powers in terms of
enforcement fining ticketing so that
would be my immediate list
thank you steve and blair any thoughts
i would just say i think at this at this
point i'm getting uh what i need and
that i need quick access to the board
and quick approvals on items such as the
one um on the agenda around the special
constable so um that that that's
terrific and if i can think of anything
else i will certainly uh let you know
thank you
and thank you blair and again we want to
just recognize the efforts of uh
chair yourself uh the mayor
uh steve canalacas in in leveraging
relationships with the federal
government while we haven't got an
absolute promise for full cost recovery
we've had good indications there this is
going to be an expensive enterprise that
will put significant pressure on the
budget without a federal relief at the
end of this
um and my final words um
this is a siege it is
something that is different in our
democracy than i've ever experienced in
my life i don't know if i'd use the word
insurrection chair but it's i don't have
a word for it so
um
it's not a demonstration it's not an
occupation it's something
and we don't have a police act that can
adequately or effectively
um
address this circumstance but we will as
we have from the beginning continue to
do our very very best with your support
the board support the mayor and city
council support um and and as we're
seeing increasingly the other two levels
of government uh coming in to support
what we're doing here so
hopefully that begins to answer your
important question i'll turn things back
over you thank you
thank you very much chief and to the two
deputy chiefs for your answer um and i
appreciate the fulsome nature of the
answer and the necessity for that um i'm
very focused on the immediate right now
because i am
concerned that we are not able to
literally and figuratively put out all
of the fires that are being started all
over the place and you know trish
described um confederation park that's
one site of many and it's happening all
over the place and so you know as much
as it's interesting to talk about all
the legal resources and everything down
the road right now
what we need to know is what do you need
right now and it sounds very much like
the answer to my question is we do not
have the resources locally that we need
to get this thing under control so what
i'm really looking to hear from you is
what do you need from us do you want us
to request the assistance of the
province the federal government do you
want us to ask them to
look to the military what do you need to
get this city back in the in peaceful
hands that's what we need to know
okay and sure again um
we will
take that away i think the best thing i
can do is take it away and try to detail
the resources you've heard some rough
numbers from trish we've had to double
our compliment that we would normally
have protecting the city
and double it on a daily basis in order
to maintain this level
depending on the nature of operation
that we go into particularly around an
interdiction enforcement operation we've
already had estimates from our public
order commanders that we would need to
bring in
as many resources as there are in the
province and potentially more than that
so we'll need to go away and and provide
a list of things but there's no quick
answer for what you're asking it's a
massive question that requires a very
detailed response
we'll be happy to engage you as we get
those numbers and then i'm not sure the
process would be for governance around
that um but again we're not waiting on
this we've been on a daily basis i have
a daily call with steve camalacas a
daily call with the mayor staff
twice daily calls with yourself i have
daily calls with brenda lucky tom karik
now into a cycle of daily calls with the
public safety minister deputy minister
everything that we can possibly do every
leverage that we can possibly bring to
bear every agency we can bring in we're
doing that
there's just so much so fast that things
can come as soon as they come like we're
doing with the rcmp offers get them
sworn in get them on the road get some
resources directed back into community
and quite frankly give some of our
people a rest for the first time in 12
days
so that's where we're at i don't have
any more information that we've been
able to give you right now we do not
have sufficient resources to adequately
and effectively address this situation
while adequately effectively providing
policing in this city
thank you and um
i'm going to turn this over to the board
members to ask their questions and then
i'll come back on so member smallwood
thank you very much can you hear me okay
yes go ahead okay great thanks very much
i i apologize my computer froze so i've
gone on to a handheld so i'm not sure if
i if this question was answered but
first of all i i just wanted to say
thank you very much chief
uh
deputy bell uh deputy ferguson or acting
deputy ferguson uh
krista and hannah i mean this has been a
really challenging time for everybody
and i really appreciate
just how challenging this has been
and uh all of the board members as well
it's uh it's something that's keeping us
very concerned and we want to see a
resolution one of the things that i
when i was hearing the the reports from
the various people
uh two things came to mind one was there
earlier being a comment about there was
some charter right uh concern about
stopping the movement of large vehicles
of trucks or stopping into mentoring the
city i'm getting the sense that that
isn't the case that there isn't a
charter protection against the movement
of vehicles and hopefully that is the
case
and that being the case i'm wondering
what resources do you need to stop these
large vehicles from entering
the core of the city the downtown
residential areas i'm not concerned
about the parliamentary streets but the
residential areas
and since i i believe there are
bylaws against idling of trucks and
sounding of horns
do you have the resources to immediately
stop
the i heard on the when there was an
injunction sought this afternoon uh
which is not going to be heard now until
one o'clock on monday there was a
comment that they would restrict their
their blaring of horns
for
12 hours a day
these are serious health issues this is
harm being called to the um
the
members of the residents of the
community this is immediate harm being
caused to them and i want to know if
there's something that can be done
immediately not waiting for an
injunction on monday to stop the idling
of trucks the pollution and the noise
and air pollution that's causing uh and
what resources do you need to go in and
do that now and this is something
further the city can be doing is there's
something that we should be asking the
city to do to help make sure that this
this gets stopped now not next week
thanks very much
thank you very much vice chair and i
will leave it
i'm not sure that you fully understood
or we've
effectively explained the charter issues
but i would invite you to to get a
response from
to get a response from um
david white on that charter matter um
in regards to
uh bylaws and that sort of thing one of
the list of items that we have discussed
over the last several days is with uh
steve cadillac as a city manager in fact
we escalated that for discussions with
the federal government today uh we need
tow trucks we need heavy tow trucks um
uh there are not enough in this in the
city uh not the availability through
private sector that would be a
significant issue should we start to try
to challenge the full breadth of what's
going on with
horn blowing ultimately we're going to
have to potentially
seize and impound vehicles around a
range range of number of issues that's
another significant resource need we
need
very quickly um
again i don't know how to answer a
question how do we stop porn blowing
what resources would we need to stop
that
but that would be one area we are seeing
some interesting
legislation being passed provincially in
the east coast around trying to prevent
the types of mass truck blockades that
have been happening here in the nation's
capital
again we've had discussions with our
federal counterparts today around how
that might work uh within ontario and
potentially as an inter-provincial
police piece between quebec and ontario
given the bridges
so we're looking at literally we've been
asking the same questions how do we
change provincial bio uh provincial
legislation inter-provincial legislation
national transportation legislation how
do we procure tow trucks municipally
provincially and federally how do we
join a procurement process with rcmp
commissioner lucky who has the same
challenges out in coots alberta trying
to find tow trucks for the trucks that
are there in a 240 person town i don't
know if i answered your question viceroy
smallwood but
the wish list continues we need tow
trucks and we need provincial
inter-provincial legislation to
whether short-term or long-term to be
able to
take out some of what's coming into the
city
before it gets here
so if i just follow up chair on that it
does
i guess one of the things and and i i
think you've said you've answered this
before but i'll ask it again is it not
possible for instance i believe there is
currently a ruling place about not
idling for more than three minutes there
are trucks idling for 24 hours is it not
possible to at least find
these vehicles that are idling endlessly
because of the damage it's doing i know
you've said that that could be viewed as
uh uh escalating the situation but
there is harm being done by those idling
vehicles so they're just
i think it's i want to understand that
that that there isn't full understanding
of the harm that that is doing to the
residents who are subjected to that and
the noise and once again with the noise
i believe there's already a noise by law
so it's really a case of enforcing the
existing rather than looking for new
legislation
okay sorry i was a little distracted so
i will answer your question just mayor
we're going to make an amendment in the
public oh well i'm going to ask you if
you could amend the second item around
the rcmp officers we've just been
advised that we have
an additional 250 in total
in total 250 rcmp officers
um so not the 50 or 60 but 250
that we're going to need to amend
and and then we'll get them deployed as
quickly as we can that's just good news
you very really get good news in the
middle of a board meeting um
so so with that with that announcement
will that i guess that means one third
of that would be on if you say uh you
know 200 you're only going over 250
you'd only have to be able to access
one-third of those at a time because of
shift requirements is that right
no it depends on how deputy chief
ferguson decides to deploy them so again
we've just found this out in real time
we'll figure out how to best deploy them
to address the biggest risks in the most
effective way possible okay
um i i should i'm sorry again we're just
answering real time just to be clear
from the day where the uh
protest the original convoy came across
the manitoba border into ontario we
embedded our police liaison teams into
the opp operations from the moment we
took over direct
coordination negotiation with the seven
original convoys we have been
negotiating with them
not to come
if they do come to come lawfully and
peacefully and respectfully
and every day that they have been here
since they've come to address things
like the horn blowing the diesel idling
everything that you have asked about the
communities complaining about our police
liaison team members have from the very
first day tried to accomplish through
negotiation and we continue to do that
to this day our police liaison team
members are probably the most overworked
next-door traffic officers in terms of
long days no days off and intense
interactions with the core of the
demonstrators we've done everything we
can and we'll continue to do so
regardless of whether or not an
injunction is hurt again at one o'clock
tomorrow
we've reduced the number of trucks that
are in the downtown core associated to
those seven uh trucks so again that's
through the negotiation of the plt in
order to reduce the overall impact of
noise from the overall number of trucks
i will turn things over to deputy chief
ferguson to maybe provide some more
answers in the short term to your
important question vice chair thank you
patricia
thank you
you chief i just want to
maybe set the the stage a little bit for
uh what you're suggesting member
smallwood would work on a reasonable
person that they would be provided a
ticket for behavior and then that
behavior would cease but this is not the
crowd that we're dealing with and so
even to
uh to stop somebody from blowing their
horn i have watched outside my window
all day officers trying to pull people
over
um first of all it puts the
motoring public at risk but even when
they do get them pulled over
um there's nothing to stop them they are
in frac given the infraction for that
moment in time
and there's nothing to stop them from
driving three blocks and beginning that
horn
going again so i just want to set that
stage because you know if we're dealing
with reasonable people um then it is a
deterrent but this is not the crowd that
we're dealing with so
just to paint that
i appreciate your answer thank you chair
thank you member smallwood member king
uh thank you chair and chief
residents as we know are being
intimidated roads transit and city
services are being obstructed
parks and other facilities such as the
baseball stadium of my ward are being
used as staging areas to provide
logistics and
transit and store hazardous materials
for unlawful occupation and residents
frankly are fed up with the truck convoy
noise and pollution that goes on for 12
hours a day and which has been making
life absolutely intolerable
you outlined the strategy in response to
the chairs uh question
residents
along with my council colleagues in the
downtown core have seen that the surge
and contain strategy over the past two
days has not resulted in a meaningful
increase in police officers in center
town sandy hill lower town or the bywood
market
when will we have a comprehensive plan
of action to end this demonstration
since that's under your jurisdiction
that addresses all of these concerns
especially concerning a substantial
increase of police patrols in
neighborhoods and when will that plan be
communicated to the board to the council
and to the public
thank you member king i really
appreciate the question i can again
sense a frustration you have and you're
championing for the very important needs
of your constituents and
obviously you're speaking on behalf of a
few other counselors who are not present
here or not able to speak so i
appreciate that take it to heart to take
it seriously because i do everything in
regards to my responsibilities and
responsibilities as police servants so
thank you very much sir i really
appreciate that
we've just outlined the framework of the
plan
we have talked about the specific
portion of the plan that relates to the
search and contain that has been
implemented it was detailed in the press
conference yesterday the board received
all communication materials and briefing
notes associated to it if you haven't
received it we can send it to you again
um we have talked about it here today
and we have deployed those officers in
even bigger numbers than we than we
presented yesterday because of our
ability to free up officers with the opp
arriving and the rcmp arriving so we
actually have a bigger number of
officers that are being deployed and as
you've just heard in real time we have
an additional
260 officers whatever coming in on top
of what we were promised and they will
go into augmenting the very things that
you talked about
exactly what we said we did we're going
to do we have done so i'm not sure where
the lack of understanding is around the
commitment to that surge of officers and
their level of engagement within the
community we've also said
we cannot cover everything and be
everywhere in the way that we would like
to be around this as a chair who said
insurrection mad democratic
attack
this is something that is just not
normal and we have provided the best
information with the best plan with the
extremely limited resources in order to
provide that level of safety and
security for your constituents that so
desperately need it and absolutely
deserve it
well a strategy that you outlined is
different in my mind than a
comprehensive plan that gives direction
uh both to the board to the council and
to the public as to uh the general
trajectory of when we'll be uh exiting
uh this demonstration so i'm gonna
continue to ask that question
because from what you outlined before
all the multiple areas whether it's a
short term medium term and long term
it's evident to us that we need to have
a comprehensive plan of action a full
guide in a sense that we can take to the
public to say this is the way that we
are going to work ourselves out of this
scenario so that's my expectation if
we're looking for adequate policing in
this jurisdiction um the last question i
have does
involve the baseball stadium
we know that that was at one point a
point for overflow of parking um to
ensure that there was less
congestion in the core
it has now transformed into a staging
area so i want to know uh what is the
plan to deal with these staging areas
such as the baseball stadium that have
emerged
not just in my ward but across the city
thank you very much councilman king and
i did outline the
eight-point framework around which the
comprehensive plan was built and i gave
you significant details in regards to
the latest three elements of it which
includes the search and contained
portions of it
should the board want even more details
i've made an offer to provide as many
more details as they can lawfully within
the confidential um in-camera meeting
and we have provided even more details
in direct confidential briefings to the
chair the mayor and council
if you feel you are inadequately advised
of the quality and quantity of that
information and ask you to consider that
as a conversation with the board and we
will provide as much information as we
are lawfully able to do so as we have
been doing so from the very beginning
uh in regards to your question about the
baseball stadium i'll turn things over
to trish ferguson thank you sir
thank you chief and thank you member
king um so since uh your email of last
night um
i think i followed up with you the
sergeant attended we have been working
with people at that site uh to try and
and i say with people at that site they
have been to a point cooperative uh but
we do recognize that that is now become
a staging area if you will and a
refueling area for them so we are
looking at um addressing and
i can't reveal all of the details of it
but we are are
looking into that area determining what
any uh working with fire department any
um hazardous material any of that type
of thing
what
avenues are available to us to enforce
uh the the the laws and and to make sure
that that's rendered safe
thank you those are my questions
thank you member king remember nerman
thank you thank you cheers
uh first of all i wish to thank
each and every member of the frontline
service of police the fire paramedic
city opp rcmp
and members from the other cities
assisting the ops
in maintaining the law and order and
safety of the residents to the best of
their abilities
my question are to the chief deputy
chief bell or the event planning chief
acting deputy chief ferguson as
appropriate
uh
if there is a strong public perception
that a different policing standard was
applied to the protests
the current protest which is going on
than to other protests that have taken
place in the city
i hope you can provide some clarity
around that perception and perhaps
correct it
in your media release of february 4th
that that was yesterday you stay it was
stated by the obs and i quote the ottawa
police service and city of ottawa will
be utilizing concrete and heavy
equipment barricades
to create no excess roadways throughout
the downtown core
during my study uh which i have done
recently uh since morning the supreme
court of canada in the matter of clayton
which was decided in 2007
has have elaborately elaborately
discussed and deliberated the powers of
the police in common law
for employing the roadblocks
so can i ask why such barricades were
not employed or planned on january 28th
i.e
before the start of this convoy protest
in ottawa
and if
those would have been planned
can you please lay out what the
situation would have been different
what we are seeing today
thank you very much member nerman i'll
just reflect on your opening remarks in
regards to comparing this
demonstration to other demonstrations
and i will reflect on the chair's
comments herself
this is an under city under siege this
is a threat to democracy this is a
nationwide
insurrection this is madness
i would concur not necessarily word by
word but with the sentiment there is
nothing to compare between what we're
going through now and anything else
we've done in this city in the past with
that said i will turn things over to
deputy chief ferguson for her comments
around the transportation plan based on
the threat intelligence information we
had
two weeks ago which led to our plan for
last weekend and what we have learned
through better intelligence and lessons
learned and other jurisdictional
approaches what we've put in place for
this weekend trish over to you
thank you chief and thank you member
nerman
i don't think we could have predicted um
what this has turned into um and and you
know i will go back to the chairs um
comments at the beginning
uh this is unprecedented uh in policing
times and in
in my i will be 28 years tomorrow with
the ottawa police service never seen
anything like it we plan for events we
plan for large scale events we plan for
dignitaries arriving
throughout the city and we are really
good at that
our members know what they're doing and
and that's what we had planned for was a
potentially weekend-long demonstration
on what this was going to be
we quickly had to reassess
and pivot uh and over the course of the
week
we maintained negotiations we we did
what
quite frankly the public expects us to
do now which is to de-escalate and
maintain a level of
safety and obviously for
those involved
we are to provide the lawful right to
demonstrate and that's what we did
initially that's what we were looking at
and throughout the week we realized that
i mean earlier than that but we realized
that this was going to be a longer more
projected event our members have been
negotiating the whole way through
and and quite frankly um doing our very
best to keep a lid on what has been for
our members some really contentious
heated volatile and dangerous situations
and we were not staffed appropriately to
do that
and so this weekend having canceled
everybody's days off we have now
provided what we what we are hoping will
be that necessary flow we we recognize
that the neighborhoods around
the um
the footprint are being very negatively
affected and we are doing everything we
can to
to make sure that they are getting the
attention that they need and and
starting with very basic
um addressing
bad behavior addressing
menacing nuisance intimidation all of
that
um
so in terms of of our approach
we will continue to do that we will be a
presence as much as we can in those
neighborhoods um and our traffic folks
are
now we can have them assigned to what
they do best which is addressing
highway traffic violations in and around
the area dangerous driving that we have
seen that we have heard from in the
neighborhoods
we have been working with kim ayotte's
team
and with bylaw
embedding them with our neighborhood
resource officers we have been in touch
with the business uh improvement
associations doing everything we can to
make sure that their needs are um are
being heard and addressed as soon as we
have the the
facilities and and the ability to do so
i don't know if i fully answered your
question remember nerman but
ah thank you uh thank you no i have a i
of course uh
my youth you are saying that
this type of crowd was not
anticipated or it is much beyond the
normal
so will it be reasonable to say there
was a lack of intelligence and you could
not uh anticipate this
maybe i remember norman i'll ask deputy
chief bell to speak to that please
thank you for your question so um we
gathered a large amount of intelligence
as from the time the convoy started as
they moved uh across the country we
worked with our rcmp opp partners and as
they came into
the national capital region we expanded
that to continue to work with our
certified quebec and gatineau police
partners
we brought in a fantastic amount
of intelligence as this progressed
um all the intelligence we had indicated
that there could be small groups that
stay could stay longer but predominantly
the approach the groups would come would
come and then go as is normal within the
course of what we normally see some
uh two to three hundred times a year in
the nation's capital so as as we
continue to say this is unprecedented
there has never been a protest that's
turned into an occupation like this on
this scale in any city across canada and
i'm not sure in any city across north
america this is a new phenomenon we're
seeing this is a new tactic to be used
around civil disobedience that has never
been seen before so the intelligence we
had did not indicate that it would go on
and continue because it's never been
done to this this extent before
i thank you deputy bell and my final uh
final comment of building on that would
be
as you would have seen uh from the
emails from the media
and the proactiveness and rightfully the
residents the citizens are fed up
do you have and i'm building on what
member king has said is there any
shorter
medium plan in hand
which you have or if be just wait and
watch
uh thunder nerman uh thank you
i can again uh get the sense of
frustration that you're articulating on
behalf of
the province that appointed you and your
sense of what ottawa should be about and
what canada should be about
um i i would
um
i would reflect on wake and watch as a
characterization of all of what we've
briefed the board on and
someone like yourself who has
taken the veil of right alongs of police
officers
and knows the dedication and the hard
work and the
dynamics of their job i think you
actually asked for a ride along during
the protest
that would not have been safe
but at some point perhaps your other
board members would like to avail
yourselves of a ride-along and you can
then at that point decide if what we are
doing is waiting and watching
again i reflect on the question again
meaningful and passionate question that
counselor king asked and that you've
echoed
uh we have done our very best and i
think more so
um well not i think i have provided
to this board around this unprecedented
demonstration more information
more briefings
more daily reports
more detailed uh information than i've
ever done in any other operation in my
entire career
if you need more we've made a suggestion
to take a veil of your own in-camera
session to receive
more detailed information what we can as
up-to-date as we can
if you are trying to ask us is there a
date that we can set your calendars on
when this will be over i can't provide
that to you
it would be irresponsible of me to do so
thank you chief and uh
i would request the chair dean
if he has a time as the chief and
deputies have a time but after this
session we move in camera for our
further questions thank you chair
thank you member member johnson
thank you chair and i'll just echo my
thanks for all of the hard work and
efforts of the command team
and the entire ops
[Music]
leading up to this eighth day of
demonstration
so during the hearing today at an auto
accord
over an injunction sought on behalf of
downtown residents a lawyer representing
three protesters
said they are willing to refrain from
honking their horns
between 8 pm and 8 a.m
the judge at the end advised them just
to honk at noon or for a shorter time
so this is tangible progress due to
communication
and if we want to make further progress
what are the pros and cons of a phased
approach
to gradually move some trucks while
discussions continue
can they continue having can you
continue having meetings
and mediation to have progress towards
ending the ottawa demonstration
what could be achieved with the plan
or an agreement to have three mediated
sessions or meetings and i realize this
may well be with public officials
but i just um
yeah so i just
wanted to say that today and take any
input you have on this thank you so much
thank you very much remember johnson i
will put trish in the batter's box
you'll talk further about the police
liaison officers the role they've played
so far to date in this
uh successful role
not anywhere near where we need to get
to but success has come a lot from it uh
and i referenced earlier on my comments
i think i've briefed the board
at least the board chair over the last
several days in the last 72 hours myself
and city manager steve cadillac has been
in meetings
with public safety canada the deputy
ministers several ministers
from sorry several deputy ministers from
several different federal ministries
um while it was a very difficult first
day we made very quick progress and
[Music]
there has been uh
an increased aperture on behalf of the
federal government to
not only provide material supports as
you've just heard about again in real
time here in the board meeting
but consider ways that they can through
discussion mediation uh assist in in a
quick safe and sustainable
contribution to our efforts here
and um
while it's really still in the
exploratory stage it is uh a daily
effort uh by two of the top civil
servants myself and
steve cadillacques supported by the
the mayor to to move that forward
um
i don't know
quite frankly of any situation that
could be described in the terms you've
heard from the chair the terms you've
heard from me and my colleagues on the
executive
that would not have some
continuous element of negotiation and
mediation to achieve a sustainable safe
solution
i outlined in that i outlined that in my
plan twice already today and other times
that negotiation is a core component of
the framework around which we are trying
to accomplish your swift uh end to this
demonstration and return this city to
normalcy so hopefully that uh that
answers your upfront question i don't
know fishy it does answer that chief it
does it was the upper end questions as i
do here have heard and i've heard from
you all week of the good work your
officers are doing to
to negotiate uh all i think you said
even every hour asking protesters to
leave
so so really i was looking to hear what
you just shared which i wasn't aware of
of this bigger picture mediation so
thank you that really that really uh
answered that question for me
um
and i guess one of the questions just
relates to a comment uh i think it was
you who made it
earlier about the need for more legal
resources
is that something that we need to
urgently be assisting you with
at this meeting or is it something he
can wait as the days unfold i just
wasn't quite sure how i heard that yeah
it was deputy chief bella made the
comment and i completely uh uh validate
that comment for a short term and a
longer term standpoint from a longer
term you'll know that we made a budget
request so it was granted by the board
for privacy lawyer not anticipating this
but to support the call referral program
and integration through community safety
well-being what deputy chief ferguson is
sorry bell is talking about is actual
legal assistance for us to find
uncharted territory steve do you want to
expand on that and give a sense of is
this a short or medium-term effort
thank you chief and thanks for the
question member johnson um i think it's
both a shorter and a medium term this is
uh we've said it a bunch of times this
is unprecedented we have um our archaic
would be a way to put it we have old
criminal code legislation we have a
provincial hta framework we have
municipal bylaws and none of them are
specifically centered or situated to
directly address a situation like this
but within there there is the ability
for us to look at the legislation look
at areas that are not commonly used and
try and leverage that to give us some
better legal ground standing to end it
and then to have prosecutions that
result from it that will require
legal minds legal perspectives and legal
advice to be able to do that i can tell
you we've had amazing legal advice to
our own internal legal services we've
leveraged legal services through the
city of ottawa through david white we
have amazing
cooperation and participation by our
crown attorney's office so we do have a
capacity around that it is an area that
we are really gonna we are really
starting to double down on are really
starting to focus on so
augmented resources when you say what
more do you need that is an area that i
think will pay great dividends for us
and one that we really need to focus on
to bring us some new areas of leverage
anything further member johnson
no thank you chad thank you
member man
thank you chair and
thank you to the command
um
can i just express my frustration with
everything
on behalf of our community
i think there was a lot of hope
yesterday chief when you outlined the
surge and contained strategy
and
the sense of urgency to get this thing
under control
despite that
i think people are expressing uh
frustration because they're not seeing
any results
to to hear that we need legal advice uh
on on what can be done to clamp down on
some of the behaviors um is um
it's baffling
there are there are there is criminal
behavior happening down there
and i think if we could see the officers
in the neighborhoods have we arrested
have we gone in and arrested the people
who are caught like
who are causing trouble at night
i think if we could see some concrete
things happening maybe people wouldn't
be so frustrated
we see correct city taking action we see
toronto taking action i mean obviously
with with hindsight look at what's going
on here but at the same time
you need officers we're getting more
officers but we need to be told
if there's a concrete plan in place that
we can start arresting people how do we
know that things are going to blow up if
we haven't done anything except monitor
and keep the peace
this can't continue and this is day
eight can i just say that knowing that
we haven't been in touch with the ncc to
decide about policing confederation park
is mind-boggling to me
can we do we have we not put all the
levels of government and the decision
makers in our room to determine because
this is an unprecedented situation that
we have to take unprecedented decisions
and move
because we're giving it the signal to
all these people who are coming into
town that it's a free-for-all
you know they can take tires off trucks
they can put up buildings they can bring
in fuel they can take over our stadium
we've given them the signal that it's a
common party in our in our town
and
and i'm expressing frustration not just
as a board member and a city councillor
but as as a resident of the city to see
about our colleagues and our our fellow
residents downtown being so hard put
upon
i believe it when i hear by city
councillors the city council's downtown
say they're there's no police presence
in the neighborhoods and people have
been left on their own we want to we
want to know what the plan is we want to
know concretely what is going to happen
are we going to start making arrests
or do we just wait for more intelligence
um
i'm assuming other cities are getting
intelligence
but they're still taking concrete action
so
please i i apologize if i'm off base
here as a board member
but we're not getting answers we're not
getting the answers that we require here
please i'm begging you
give us some answers
what's going to be done here
okay thank you
member ian again as you've expressed and
others on the call
great passion and uh
empathy for those that have suffered the
most and as a
long serve long resident of ottawa
frustration to see your city in the
circumstances as a new resident ottawa
share that in every aspect that you've
articulated so well
um you asked a question about whether or
not we had a level of coordination going
into this i will ask deputy chief
ferguson to describe
uh the intersect
model around which this and all of our
other operations
are built on i'll then asked deputy
chief bell to talk about the arrests and
the charges that we have laid
and the investigations that are underway
and the status as much as we can share
on a call like this so trish if you can
help the
member to understand uh how we integrate
with all the other agencies not just
policing but
ncr related agencies and then over to
stephen
i can't chief um thank you remember me
and the um intersect is a national
capital region and it involves
all of the parties in the area and we
have monthly calls to share information
i can tell by your reaction that that's
not what you're interested in hearing
right now and i i can certainly
appreciate we are as frustrated as you
but every one of these situations that
arises
we we can't take the law into our own
hands you demand that of us to
we have to be the level head and we have
to be the ones who are responding based
on the authorities that we have got and
they don't change in this situation no
one has wanted us with powers to arrest
if we don't have them we still have to
follow the charter of rights we still
have to go by the trespass to property
act if if the ncc is the owner of the
confederation park we have to get their
approval before weighing in on those
things so we are we we are trying to
abide by all of these things because
there's no point in making arrests and
and
a whole lot of effort and energy if it's
only going to be tossed out later in
court because we've we haven't abided by
we we know these things from past
protests from other people's decisions
from from what's happened through the
courts what i will say is places like
quebec city toronto they have learned
from us absolutely we're not saying we
didn't make any mistakes we're saying we
are learning as we go on a lot of these
things and we are doing the best we can
every one of us is so we cannot can we
not get the ncc to give us approval to
go on to confederation park and
dismantle this
core this this party central
we have that and i can tell you that we
have made progress in the last three
hours while i've been on calls with
people that's happening i can't tell you
exactly what's happening right now
because i can't be there but i can tell
you that our folks have been
they haven't abandoned the the goal here
they are working through it methodically
and in in
by lawful powers that we have and we
nothing has changed we have as i said
have not been granted all kinds of new
powers because this has happened in our
city as much as everybody everybody has
power in this city
except the police and residents
that's what that's the message that
we're giving to this to the protesters
in this city
that's i'm sorry that's what
for the last
frustrated residents we appreciate
everything that the police are doing
we do and i understand that they're
exhausted
but this is day eight
and we need to know that this is going
to end and right now i think everybody i
think if if you're listening to this i
think there's nothing that indicates
that we're not going we're not in for
more days of this so um
i'll just stay quiet from now on um i
apologize uh yes i am and passionate but
um
i have to be on behalf of everybody that
that is feeling very very helpless right
now thank you
thank you member man members did
remember me and want to care about the
arrests i just wasn't sure if that was
the end of her question
um
if you ever
yes i'd love to hear about who's been
arrested and i'd like to know what's
going to happen tonight when there's
bonfires and more parties and more
honking i'd like to know what's going to
happen
thank you um and and i share your
frustration about when this is going to
end i think you'd like to know when
there will be an end to coveted what was
the detailed plan to end colbit but that
was an unprecedented pandemic
and there is no detailed plan for these
things but
deputy fell could you provide an update
on the status of our criminal arrests
criminal investigations hate crime
investigations multi-jurisdictional
investigations yup thank you uh very
much chief so um as i indicated earlier
we have over 400
calls for service directly to the
protest area that's resulted in the
initiation of 50 criminal investigations
uh 11 of which are hate crime
investigations uh from that we've had so
far four persons charged with a total of
seven offenses there are um several
investigations contained from all of the
50 of the investigations are continuing
the other ones that have been culminated
by charges including that is the
mischief um around the
tomb of the unknown soldier that
investigation does progress and is
progressing well and we hope to have
announcements on that in the coming days
as well as some
threats that we've received to various
public figures that has resulted in an
invested cooperative investigation with
the federal bureau of investigations in
the united states and we hope to have
positive announcements around
culmination of that in the near future
ever we have dedicated teams that from
both a hate crime perspective and a
criminal investigative perspective that
are following up
actively and aggressively to charge uh
to investigate and charge people
involved in criminal activities around
the protest
okay thank you member man member
suede you chair and um i also really
want to thank the chief and all the
members of the police service
for all the hard work um and i really
want to urge everyone
to stay patient and
calm and
just everybody
on every side of this issue to remain
peaceful at times are getting a little
bit more tense
and uh we just need to everybody remain
calm to ensure that there's a successful
and peaceful resolution to this
chief you know i know you mentioned that
you have a lot of resources from the
province and from the federal government
and that's great it's going to help
alleviate the pressure on on the ops
members
and also
have more more boots on the ground
but has there been any attempt for any
political resolution to this matter
because i understand you know the
policing aspect is one aspect and a very
important aspect however i'm just
wondering if there's more of a political
angle to this and and is that something
you can share with us
thank you very much member sweden um and
again
attempted to but maybe not effectively
um you know from the start of the week
as i was reflecting on the first
four or five days of this
situation it was clear to me that it was
not going to be as an alone
policing solution to the circumstances
that the chair is already so eloquently
uh described in her own way
and others have echoed in their own way
um and it was at that time we started to
work even more closely with through the
chair and her help and steve kanilakis
to get meetings with the book with the
mayor
uh deputy mayors and other counselors
that were involved directly
uh member kane has mentioned earlier on
council menard mckinney
fleury
leaper in the downtown areas all were
involved in those discussions
so we have elevated our
operational plan
to involve engagement with the municipal
level i have had reported to the board
and to council several times this week
i have had direct conversations with
minister jones lister general uh deputy
minister of solicitor general mario de
tomaso
to engage their efforts in not only
providing material resources but to
raise situational awareness and to
engage encourage them to have their own
ministerial and interministerial
discussions around how they can help to
support our efforts here in ottawa and
to alert them even at that point that
this was going to be a situation that
was already nationwide and was going to
spread to other locations in the
province and which indeed it has in
toronto in sudbury in windsor in
hamilton and other locations
i've told you i think two occasions
again this evening the efforts of steve
canalakas and myself
uh on the last three days two different
meetings with the federal government
some of which have resulted in material
resources like the 250 plus offices in
the rcmp all of which were accomplished
on thursday evening into friday and as a
result of today's phone call which
deputy chief bell joined me on
today
we have encouraged material resources
for policing operations and received
significant particularly from the
province well from all three levels of
government municipal provincial and
federal have all made significant police
resource
contributions to our efforts over the
last eight days and we have had from the
city of ottawa um
indications from the federal government
that they are
uh
understanding our context here and
appreciating that there are other
opportunities to support us beyond the
policing public safety as well i
obviously cannot speak for any other
level of government municipal provincial
or federal
but we've had a tremendous response
locally
we are having an increasingly strong
response federally and there are lines
of communication open provincially all
of which myself and my command team have
been directly involved in facilitating
if not actually leading those efforts i
think more can and should be done
in those areas and i've had
communication formal communication with
chair deans on that matter and
encouraging the chair and the board to
consider all avenues around that i think
that is why this was called today i
think that's why the question was asked
by the chair and i think that's the bulk
of the information we've provided here
today we need people we need assets we
need capability we need legal advice we
need investigators we need intelligence
we'll need a paycheck somewhere down the
road otherwise we're going to have some
strong budget issues
but most of all we need a solution that
is beyond a police solution for
something that is not a policing issue
it's a societal issue and again the
chair has eloquently described that more
more so than i could so i don't know if
that answers your question sir it has
been part of our strategy a developing
part of our strategy increasing over the
last week and i suspect will continue to
increase as we go forward
that's the
the main point i was trying to ask chief
was that
we know that you you're you're doing
your best and you've gotten many
resources
from various levels of government
uh it was more
uh how do we address the underlying
societal issue
i mean obviously these protesters are
here and came from every corner of the
country to protest an underlying issue
and it's it's basically fallen in our
laps and in your lap chief and that's
why i was hoping to see if there was any
indication that our uh our political
leadership is going to get involved to
address these societal issues that you
mentioned
so thank you very much chair
okay um
i don't see any other hands up so thank
you to the board members for your
questions um chief i called this meeting
today to ask a specific question which
was do you have the
resources you need to
provide adequate and effective policing
in the city of ottawa and the answer
that i heard from you is no
even though you got in the middle of the
call 250 more rcmp officers um what what
has been described in all of the open
fronts all over the city um is that you
are overwhelmed we the police service
has been overwhelmed and that this is
bigger than the police service and i
needed to hear that answer today because
we need to take extraordinary action and
maybe it's something that member suede
was getting at but i have some questions
for our legal counsel david david white
because what i'm hearing on this call is
you know we're taking one criminal
charge at a time but there are so many
people out there engaged in a broader
act of um
mayhem that uh we need we need to be
able to bring it all under control and
i'm wondering what levers there are i'm
wondering if we could be using and this
is to you david white
if we could be using section 63 of the
criminal code
unlawful assembly and if it would be
possible to get a judge to declare under
that section of the criminal code an
unlawful assembly which i understand
would allow the mayor to then declare a
riot and in
uh turn would allow us to
um
do some mass arrests now of course we
would need people to do that but it
would at least allow us to address the
situation i know others have talked
about an injunction so i would like to
hear the legal
aspects of what we can do to bring this
under control now
counselor all of those things are things
that my office
and my team are looking at all in
conjunction with their colleagues with
the ottawa police um there is no
singular answer as you've heard from a
policing perspective there's no singular
legal answer as to
what
um levers we might pull um what orders
we might obtain
to bring this to an end
the work that my office is doing is all
with a view of of assisting and
supporting the operational plans that
are being put in place
by ottawa police and their their law
enforcement um
colleagues
so with respect to section 63 uh we have
looked at that from our perspective uh
chair that is a somewhat archaic section
um we have not actually been able to
find any occasion where it's been
invoked
um
and again you know
doing taking these steps even taking the
steps of an injunction for example
um
one there are
there are certain challenges that are
associated with that
um
in the in from an operational context um
there are challenges that that come from
a legal context as well
um as you as you saw today with the the
effort to obtain an injunction
um in the the class action that's been
commenced the
[Music]
the
you know the judge hearing that opined
that he's not even sure how he would
frame an order that would be
effective and enforceable so
these are all things that as i say my
office is examining um
and we'll provide updates you know
either through
through the police as those
kind of operational imperatives develop
um or through counsel
certainly if we believe that there is a
um an effective tool that can be
deployed then that is something that
we're looking at
mr white how long will it take because
we are in such a crisis situation uh i
would think we
would want to be in court today asking
if we could
use the criminal code section 63 to
declare an unlawful assembly we need to
get on with this now so like i don't
i don't know what the legal roadblocks
are i understand that you have to put a
case together but this is an urgent
situation so how long will it take to
get to court to get a declaration that
we need to arrest this situation
counselor again our chair my apologies
chair
whether the the
the route
to resolving this is one that that ends
with mass arrests
um is not a decision that my office can
make as you can appreciate as to whether
that is a viable tool is a discussion
that that obviously we have with
our our
colleagues we're in constant uh contact
with
the chief's legal counsel
in that regard
um
as i say if there is a view that that
these are
an effective tool that will that can
serve to bring this to a peaceful
conclusion then those are certainly
things that we will pursue
would asking the mayor to declare a
state of emergency
have any immediate positive impact on
this situation
chair from the standpoint of legal
authority
the the declaration of an emergency
under the emergency management civil
protection act
does little it may provide some um
relief
from the
some of the strictures that we operate
under from a procurement standpoint but
it does not imbue
the mayor or
the the city with any additional legal
authority there are provisions for
example if the province declares an
emergency um they are there are specific
powers that exist in
in the premier and in the provincial
cabinet
but
from the you know beyond the the kind of
symbolic
um
value of the declaration of a state of
emergency under the provincial
legislation there's no additional
authority that would provide either to
the city or the police
is mr white can you perhaps tell us who
has the authority to declare a state of
emergency that will give us the tools
that we need to bring this
to a halt is it the province of ontario
is it the federal government under the
emergencies act who is it
sarah i regret i'm just i'm not in a
position
to tell you as to
which level of government or or who
might exercise the authority to bring
this to an end quite frankly without an
idea as to what will what is necessary
to bring this situation to an end as
you've heard from the chief and others
that the situation that the city of
ottawa finds itself as the
as the the place that this is happening
um
this is it
it is certainly from from my experience
this is unprecedented um there are
authorities as you say with respect to
uh declarations of emergency
the federal legislation um i think what
you're referring to is the emergencies
act that that
was passed in 1988
um as the as the successor to the war
measures act there are extraordinary
powers or that are available under that
um that is a as you can expect an
extraordinary step
um
there are you know there are
sections we don't obviously deal with it
with the municipality there are sections
that that provide for the declaration of
a public order emergency
um but i am not aware of any instance
that they have been invoked certainly
in decades
well this in my mind is an extraordinary
emergency and we need extraordinary
measures and i believe that we need to
ask every level of government to use the
powers and the authorities that they
have to declare the emergencies that we
need to bring this situation to
um a peaceful ending this uh
we cannot allow this kind of
terrorism in our community to continue
in this way and so i would implore
our legal minds to tell us what we need
to do today who we need to ask for what
authority to help us to bring this to a
conclusion
member nerman
thank you chair
you have raised the good points and uh
maybe david white can
either endorse it or correct me
uh coming back on section 63 of the
criminal code
i don't think there is any roadblock or
we need any judicial declaration under
section 63 i think police can simply
invoke that power
chair with respect to
you know again i would simply reiterate
as to what what are considered to be
effective tools
that will
serve to
resolve this without escalation without
violence
that is that is a discussion that we are
having regularly um
with
our colleagues at the ottawa police
as i say if
you know the the operational view is
that that will
allow
this matter to be resolved
in a peaceful fashion
that is something that we will certainly
pursue
thank you david i think i will i will
build on what member suiter and then the
chair deans have said that
uh if that is the intention and of
course uh
there may be a
political will or political solution to
this and we should be looking at all the
options a chief has been saying that all
options are on the table
so possibly i would like to hear what my
other reverend members
have their thoughts going forward thank
you chair
thank you member nerman just wanna i i
this is very very important and we need
to get to the bottom of it i'm also
mindful that our police service we're
taking time so we have to be cautious
about that too remember suede
thank you chair um and uh thank you mr
white
uh
mr white just building on what remember
nerman said and what that what the chair
was saying
we find ourselves that we have our local
chief of police having to deal with
you know not only a local issue but of
eventual nationwide and international
issue
um and i just want to you touched on
something you mentioned that
uh even if section three is invoked
whether we can invoke it uh whether the
chief can invoke it or whether a judge
rules on it
um
what about the enforceability so even
though it's invoked the question becomes
is it enforceable are we able to enforce
it given the situation
chair i i defer to the the chief and his
team
that is one of the challenges that that
we are always faced with with respect to
for example even in the context of an
injunction
um and as you as you may have heard from
the judge today is
those those orders that may exist
legally but whether they are practically
enforceable is an entirely different
question
so
so basically you know the situation is
the same whether we invoke certain
sections of the law or not the
situation's the same how can we come to
a peaceful resolution regardless of
whatever section is invoked is that what
i'm hearing uh mr white
yes chair
thank you chair
thank you member suede and member meehan
thank you chair i've calmed down a bit
um
i will ask this question i just got some
information
and it is that uh could i ask david
white about part four of the national
defense act
called aid of the civil power which
states if there is a riot or disturbance
the feds can't send in the military
it's i guess it's not the same as the
war measures act but because it is this
has to do with a federal issue
and the protesters
have are taking issue with the feds and
and provincial policies
um
does anybody know about
this civil national defense act
can we can somebody look about that
or
david
mr white sure happy to review um
obviously you know the invoking federal
powers is something that is going to be
exclusively within the authority of the
federal government
okay
okay so there seems to be there could
possibly be a tool there chair i'm
wondering if um we can make a direction
either to you as the chair of this board
uh to
uh reach out to the federal government
we have several ministers who are
representing ottawa ridings uh minister
forte
uh we also have opposition members from
this area that
we can convene ask the fed for the prime
minister to get involved in this
the premier of the province
and everybody in a position of power
uh to make this a top priority that we
come up with a solution to this uh we
can't allow this to continue for another
week in our city
um would a direction uh be
in order
probably not necessary but certainly if
you would like to direct me to do that i
think i will do it anyway what i heard
today is that we should be asking
everyone who has power to act to act now
because we are in a crisis situation and
so there are other levels of government
that have more power than we have that
could enact
pieces of legislation that could set
curfews in place and that could
reduce the risk to the public and we
need to ask every single level of
government to push the labors that they
have that will most effectively bring
about the end to this so if you want to
give me a direction you can but i think
i understand it i i would like to give
you a direction and i'm hoping that the
other members of the board will will
support me in that
the prime minister has to make a
statement on this they're not going to
go away until they hear from him
um he can't ignore this anymore
this is in his front yard this is his
city as long as well as our city and
the federal government have resources
that they can mobilize legal resources
that uh you know we don't we can't
access access ourselves right now um we
have to use every tool available in a
toolbox in order to bring this to uh
successful and a peaceful closure and
get our city back uh into uh a peaceful
mode um
everybody's on the breaking point we
have kovit uh we're worried that this uh
you know the everybody who's unmasked
and wha and forcing others to unmask are
going to be this is going to be a super
spreader event whether they're outside
or not
there's children down there there's a
newborn baby down there in a truck uh
this is unconscionable
um i i respectfully ask that you do
everything in your power chair um to
pull all the uh powers to be together in
order to come up with a concrete plan
to end this as a police board i think
that we have heard that we need more
help and more resources and we need the
assistance of the federal and provincial
governments to do their part what i'm
not going to do is tell the prime
minister how to do his job and i i'm
sorry but i'm not sure that um meeting
with terrorists is something that he's
going to do and i'm not going to tell
him how to do his job he can make those
decisions but i would ask both the
federal and provincial governments to um
use the levers of power that they have
to assist us to bring this under control
and chief just um a last question to you
um before we do the second part of the
agenda and then if there's still a
desire to go on camera we can go in
camera
but i wondered if you could provide a
final list of additional ask from the
police
board
by noon tomorrow that you need from us
uh thank you can can i just ask you
potentially to give some more discretion
to the timing
um
this is a team that's on its 13th
straight day we're still in the middle
of a demonstration
what was a half hour board meeting is
now almost
uh two hours and we're going into in
camera
my operational commanders are on this
call and
that's a big list we've given you a
starting point we'll try to fine tune it
but please can you just give us a little
more flexibility on the deadline to come
back as soon as possible thank you so
much